yeah hello and welcome to this video
which is a record game on Glee chess
what to do okay let's start with the
spoon I'm not going for panko this time
let's do something else
let's go for the tingle someone recently
asked about this or putting applying
that if you can play the other kind
which is bad and wise and you can also
play the two knives tangle which is bad
linking and both is not true
black nuts thing was actually quite
decent so here we transpose to a line
that looks a lot like atoms Oh
interesting
okay do we go with d6 here one d6 and
somehow d5 looks a little bit irritating
cannot move the night Queen eight four
take it take it take c3 the ship takes
then I don't know now I can go back now
I think I'll cancel that should be okay
on the other hand if it was a three now
okay which it doesn't
now I go d6 and white is playing really
quickly okay
a quick decision not sure this is all
that great now I can go to e7 which I
prefer to going back got an interesting
question is where to put this 996 that
would be completely clear if the point
would be on e4 I mean in this case I
would actually win a pawn but
okay don't you grab some space there on
the queenside
c6 was also very decent move to me or
not just felt I wasn't totally sure
about it well here Bishop f5 comes it
comes into consideration now let's do it
before I can take C 3 that should be a
bad decision and you move here to move
the Queen again basically two should be
three maybe Bishop d3 is playable push
up c3 then Bishop f5 it's very strange
variation but I can take take on c3 then
here's to take with the with the Queen
nope goes back yeah okay
let's tie the certain out of how to play
this I'll play here that that's a move
that will fit into most things give the
bushel square
really whites position doesn't look
particularly threatening but I'm still
don't don't see anything super grade
maybe be three now for white and then a
three it feels it's normal at same what
can try to play for a thrombi four okay
where are you going with this thing 57
maybe
maybe we'll probably play Quincy to
again
twenty-seven
yeah Queen d7 you go play p3 I guess
Netherlands doesn't look great really
let's go push 87 go back yellow in the
Queen c2 no it just puts it back oh yeah
so c6 now White has to take basically I
wonder if that is a good idea certainly
playable but okay well 96 is probably
pushing t3 another idea is to just take
and play 94 and and f5
not sure if c6 is good it's certainly
not bad but is it really giving me in a
good position I mean he has lost quite
some time with his maneuvers him but he
just wait for a moment and see what he
does I don't quite believe in c6 he and
some b6 is basically giving up on that
idea at least c6 takes BTech c6 it's not
going to happen
let's not not exactly easy for white
that makes the capture and 94 a little
bit more interesting maybe yeah I'm
going to go for it
Capri move 94 basically yeah is he going
to keep it now visually ones possible
and this is not necessarily a bad thing
out to put the bishop on you one looks a
bit sir passive but it can easily be
activated later so I'm not unhappy with
my prospects here on the kingside from a
structural point of view this is a quite
healthy position I don't have a bad
piece and um yeah even g5 96 and so on
isn't completely out of the picture I
expect them to play d3 m4a3 and then
before it takes a while but this is the
only thing as C five-foot-four for wide
yeah what is he going to play 92 often
it's a good recipe against the night
only for to move there 3 9 and player 3
but this is really difficult to to get
in
yeah 95 is most obvious but I'm just
going back isn't bad a threatening form
well but that can never be a bad move
the question is do I go f4 immediately
that is not no it's the piece
come on let's appease angling for 9 H
for 25 okay I have Bishop a4 here as
well the night goes back yeah this is
that is okay that that drives this night
away and I can now try to win in a
direct attack in 93 I mean here this it
is not enough to you have to try to win
by checkmate in this position it just
just go to some kind of ending it's not
enough here
and i g9 h 425 will completely killing
white yeah it's a bit of a shame it was
an interesting position this also
threatens 90s III
and now what's the quickest way this
probably 4-h club yessuh always easy to
attack when you just have an extra do I
have a win just with chicks vs. this is
easy and made age to RG to know it's a
bit silly to promote King XL okay yeah
they'd love them unfairly equal ish
position I think until he gave me gave
me the piece I mean I was quite happy
with my chances but it wasn't anything
special
even 93 so we transpose it to a new zoo
Indian style position I didn't like this
all that much because of d5 I felt that
was a bit a bit irritating yeah so not a
good idea probably to allow it
like cancels first he wins III but t6 we
should be trouble of course there you
can certainly play that it doesn't look
like it puts lots of pressure on me but
it's it's normal
[Music]
sometimes you don't know what you really
want to win it and okay so you find I
have no idea what Tryphon is doing why
should I he five looks completely normal
and yeah this disgust cares this gives
Bishop f5 with temple so Queen c2
doesn't really do much it's still again
that's fairly held equally age six looks
simple move NTIA Bishop plus seven is
sound just basically taking or saying
okay I'll take the candy yeah b6 you
control live and debate about it's not
really necessary this was another option
here takes takes but I wasn't sure about
this position yeah III exactly and this
I didn't like I mean really to a seven
somehow I didn't like this okay this
this is all kind of normal and now I
decided to chuckle for this go at five
so then at least you have an idea what
to do with even g5 as possible yeah
Bishop t3 is probably not that great
just loses more time and why is that
why is that just a mistake that a
blunder in terms of the engine with
strange a blunder the full piece okay so
we should see - yeah for something that
I was considering and it looks good
again again space this is getting more
more scope and this is an interesting
position I'm threatening now the
exchange SEC so wide probably should
react - laughs yeah I'm not sure if
everybody threatening it but if it is an
option also this is somewhat under
attack even though there's Bishop h7
Kirkland yeah it is it's fine but it's
not as generous as Valley I know but now
you get this this is only attacking
position when many things win Baba yeah
I don't think you need to look at this
umm yeah why turn what blunder here was
was kind of clear what Crosswhite the
game it's already quite comfortable I
think white didn't really had some such
a clear picture what he wanted to do and
usually you want to play on the
queenside and this is here taking still
quite a while well I still have where
I've already made some progress on the
kingside okay guys thanks for watching